MÁIRTÍN JAMESIE: Pé ar bith céard eile
a gheall Dia do Mheáirt Mór Ó Cinnéide
Bhaile an Droichid, níor gheall
sé mórán foighide dhó.
Níl aon mhaidin ná aon tráthnóna
sa tseachtain nach bhfuil sé
ina chogadh dearg idir é fhéin
agus na beithígh. Sílim nach raibh
Cóilín a chanadh i bhfad as bealach
nuair a dúirt sé gur ar na beithígh
a bhronn Dia an fhoighid agus
gur ar Mheáirt fhéin a bhronn sé
an bhúiriúch. Tá an teist iontu le
cupla lá ach tá an vet le theacht
aríst inniu, go bhfeicfidh sé
ar síos nó suas a chuaigh siad.
MEÁIRT: Gabh isteach!
Gabh isteach! ... a dhiabhail!
MEÁIRT: Nár thuga Dia slán
aníos amach.... [?]Thíos...
MEÁIRT: Gabh isteach ansin
a dhiabhail, gabh isteach.
COLM: Lie down!
COLM: Fógair air a Mheáirt! Fógair air!
COLM: Ní fhágfaidh sé
buidéal ar tóin an phub!
MEÁIRT: Come back here you! Come back
here bitch! Right down a deirim leat!
COLM: Go on! Go on! Go on!
COLM: Á dhiabhail, á déanfaidh sí staggers...
déanfaidh sí staggers de bhuidéil...
MEÁIRT: Mallacht dílis Dé dhuit mar mhada.
Get out out of that!
WINNIE: Ach cén diabhal ná deamhan atá
ar an mbeirt agaibh chor ar bith?
MEÁIRT: Bhuel dhá mbeadh gunna agam, dhéanfainn
dhá leith de dhroim an mhada sin, agus
trí leath don ghaimhnín. Go out, a dhiabhail,
get out! Cén mhaith a deirinn dhuit a bheith
ag craith do dhrioball anois, nuair
atá an diabhal déanta agat?
COLM: Seas roimpe Winnie
maith an bhean.
COLM: Á dar Dia tiocfaidh sé isteach
thríd an bhfuinneog.
MEÁIRT: ...dhiabhal eicínt,
ná bí i do sheasamh i do staic ansin!
WINNIE: Ah fágaigí an bealach an
bheirt agaibh, a dhá spleantair!
COLM: Ara muise a Winnie, tá do
cheird agat. Acha suas a Mheáirt!
COLM: Acha suas a dhiabhail ó chois go cois!
Gan gleo gan torann a Mheáirt!
COLM: Á, dar Dia, níl a fhios againn [...]
dhul i ndiaidh [...] a dheartháir.
WINNIE: Ní fhaca mé a dhá leiciméara ariamh
sa saol nach raibh ábalta rud eicínt a dhéanamh,
WINNIE: ach an bheirt agaibh.
Bhfuil mórán briste aige?
COLM: Ah, tá a fhios ag Dia go bhfuil,
a Winnie. Ach buidéil folamh iad.
MEÁIRT: Gabhfaidh mé leis an
diabhal de chosa mar bhullán.
WINNIE: Ah, ní dochar é. Nach
fearr briste iad ná cois duine.
COLM: Níl aon dochar ann, a Mheáirt,
an bhfuil a fhios agatsa go bhfuil
COLM: na buidéil bhriste sin thar cionn
in áit a mbeadh francaigh.
COLM: Staggers a dhéanamh dhaoibh
agus iad a scaoileadh síos sna poill.
COLM:  Ó, diabhal francach níos mó a Mheáirt.
WINNIE: Ara, fág ansin go fóilleach iad,
agus ólfaidh muid cupán tae.
COLM: Á tá a fhios ag Dia nach mbacfaidh mé leis,
a Winnie. Mar tá Mattie do m'iarraidh(?) ar an
COLM: chlár radio ar maidin, mar gheall ar
Oireachtas Rath Cairn. Is dar lán an leabhair
COLM: nuair atá baslach buailte
ar dhuine, is chaon tsórt,
COLM: ní aireoidh an t-am ag sciorradh a Winnie.
WINNIE: Bhuel, le cúnamh Dé, bhuel
ní bheidh sé i bhfad go bhfeicfidh mise
WINNIE: Ráth Chairn. Ó cloisim
chuile dhuine dhá mholadh!
MEÁIRT: Níor fhága chuile theach cattle crush.
Ní bhrisfidís mórán buidéal an uair sin.
COLM: Tá a fhios ag Dia muis, a Winnie,
go gcaithfidh tú a dhul ann. Bhuel a leithéide
COLM: de dheireadh seachtaine, mé fhéin
agus an mháistreás, agus bhí a bhainteach
COLM: in éineacht linn an créatúr.
MEÁIRT: Ah, ceann eile a bhfuil fonn rantáil
uirthi. Agus gan a fear bliain i dtalamh fós.
COLM: Ah, muise an créatúr, bhí sé in am aici
corraí amach. Chuirfeadh sí pian i do thóin.
COLM: Tá a fhios ag Mac Dia nach raibh mise
ag iarraidh corraí, murach máistreás na scoile.
COLM:  Ah, dar m'anam, nach dtiocfadh a Pheigí
a deirimse. Beidh an vet ag tíocht ag Meáirt,
COLM: a deirimse, is caithfidh mé láimh a
thabhairt dhó. Á, ní raibh an-mhaith a léamh...
MEÁIRT: Ah, joyrider eile.
COLM: Á, diabhal maith a bhí ann.
Diabhal a miste liom mar sin a deirimse,
COLM: ara is fad an t-aistear é, a Mheáirt,
á diabhal a leithéide de phíosa
COLM:  shaothraigh mé ariamh. Ní
dhriveáileadh máistreás na scoile sin
COLM: carr asail a Winnie. Sílim, slán
an tsamhail, go bhfuil a cosa róghearr
COLM: le meáchan ceart a chur ar na ceaipeannaí.
MEÁIRT: Huh, tá a teanga sách fada muis.
COLM: Ach is í an bhaintreach a dhriveáil abhaile.
M'anam gurb in í an cailín a bhain an deatach aisti.
COLM: Á dar Dia, is fhearr dhom rith. Tá sé
thar am radio a Winnie, lá maith agaibh.
WINNIE: Go dtuga Dia slán
abhaile thú, a Chóilín.
MEÁIRT: Tabharfaidh, a mh'anam,
mar diabhal Dia ná duine
MEÁIRT: ag iarraidh an bhruíon sin.
Caith síos braon tae, a Winnie!
MEÁIRT: gCeapann tú go bhfuil béal ar bith ormsa?
[MUSIC]
MÁIRTÍN JAMESIE: Tá Baile an Droichid
ar fad ag faire ar an mbaintreach
MÁIRTÍN JAMESIE: mar a bheadh cat
ag faire ar luch. Ní raibh dé ná deatach
MÁIRTÍN JAMESIE: le bliain uirthi, ó fuair
a fear bás, ach le cupla mí anuas,
MÁIRTÍN JAMESIE: tá sí fhéin agus
máistreás na scoile fíorluaineach.
[MUSIC]
PEGGIE: Ó, Jesus a Phil, we can't go this
meeting gan frigging idea eicínt againn!
PHIL: Breathnaigh, a Pheggie, déanfaidh muid
drama barrúil a bhainfeas gáirí amach.
PHIL: Tá mé fed up den dryrot seo,
Shakespeare agus Beckett, ara uch
PHIL: Christ chuirfidís
pian i do leath deiridh.
PEGGIE: Bhuel is é an idea atá agamsa
a Phil, ná dráma worthwhile.
PEGGIE: a dtiocfadh daoine ag breathnú
air, agus d'fhéadfadh muid a dhul ag na
PEGGIE: drama festivals
ar fud na tíre leis.
PEGGIE: Bheadh an chraic
mighty againn Phil.
PHIL: Ní dóigh liomsa go bhfuil agat ach
dhá choice. John B. Keane nó
PHIL: Johnny Chóil Mhaidhc. Sin iad atá
feiliúnach d'aisteoirí faoin tuath.
PEGGIE: Seans go bhfuil tú ceart. Imagine
Meáirt mór ag tógáil páirt Shakespeare.
PEGGIE: "Friends, Romans, countrymen,
lend me your cattle crush!".